hurricanes floods wildfires 2021 brought
more than its fair share of natural
disasters and as well as claiming around
10 000 lives they also took a major
financial toll german reinsurer munich
ray says it was one of the most
expensive years on record with the
global damages estimated at around 280
billion dollars only 120 billion dollars
of that was insured hardest hit was the
united states which accounted for 150
billion dollars of the damages it was
struck by hurricane ida disastrous
tornadoes an extremely cold winter in
the south and wildfires in the west
meanwhile let's look at europe floods
did the most damage there 54 billion
dollars worth in total last year's
flooding in western germany was the
country's worst and most costly natural
disaster on record meanwhile let's look
at asia the asia-pacific region saw
damages of 48 billion dollars but a mere
eight billion of that was actually
covered by insurance so what made 2021 a
remarkable year for natural disasters
well that's a question i put to chief
climate and geoscientists at munich re
and ralph
well 2021 proved to be the second
costliest year ever for the insurance
industry with respect to losses from
natural catastrophes
the total bill came at 120 billion us
dollars
uh the record before was set in 2017
with 146 billion us dollars so in 2021
we had for instance a major hurricane
hurricane ida in the united states of
america where this event alone did cost
the insurance industry some 36 billion
us dollars
and from a european perspective we had
this major flash flooding event in july
in germany and neighboring countries
holland and belgium and this event
resulted in insured losses of 13 billion
us dollars so there were a couple of
major events uh
contributing to this second highest
record number for the insurance industry
in 2021
are we talking about an issue of climate
change here if it would appear that the
number of natural disasters is trending
upwards
uh well that's indeed the case in some
regions and with some perils
what we cannot prove is with respect to
the data we are analyzing at munich is
that worldwide losses from natural
disasters are increasing it's mainly
events from flooding and so called
convective storms and there are two main
drivers the one is simply the
socio-economic changes so increase in
population and wealth and with
increasing wealth we obviously uh have
to expect higher losses as well
but the other factor is not really
man-made in a strict sense yes it is
climate change contributing uh from the
emissions of carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases and here we
see changing weather patterns
especially increasing probabilities and
intensities of severe weather events and
the
flash floods which we have seen in
germany and
neighboring countries in 2021 is a good
example
science with attribution studies clearly
tells us that the probability of such
events has increased over time driven by
climate change global warming higher
temperatures and higher moisture content
in the atmosphere right so how do people
and businesses react to that increased
probability is it a case of just
covering yourself with insurance
well the the first and most important
step is to get informed informed about
your local and regional exposure to
different types of natural perils
that can be river flooding it can be
flash floods
it can be tropical cycle it really
depends on where you live and only if
you inform yourself and that's
individuals it's homeowners businesses
but also risk manager in in the public
sector so only if you know about your
local risk situation you can take
actions an action can be
mitigation measures or lot loss
prevention measures
anything from drainage systems water
tight
windows for instance hardening of roofs
when it comes to damages from high wind
speeds but the ultimate solution also
can be to buy more insurance coverage
for your property
okay so work out what the risks are and
prepare yourself for them and rauk from
munich thank you so much for joining us
on tw business